welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Quichua Rizvi an associate professor
of the history of art at Yale she is an
historian of Islamic art and
architecture professor Rizvi has written
on representations of religious and
imperial authority and south of it Iran
as well as on issues of gender
nationalism and religious identity and
modern Iran and Pakistan she's the
author of the Safavid dynastic shrine
history religion and architecture in
early modern Iran and she's the editor
of modernism and the Middle East
architecture and politics in the 20th
century today we'll talk with professor
Rizvi about her new book project the
transnational mosque architecture and
historical memory in the contemporary
Middle East
welcome professor is fading Kimberly so
let's begin with an overview of the
project tell us about it
right my book really concentrates on
what is possibly the most ubiquitous
form of architecture in the Muslim world
generally which is the mosque that is
you could be in Muslim communities from
China to Europe from Beirut to Timbuktu
and the mosque will be the one
architectural form that unites them
historically the mosque has been around
since at least the time of the Prophet
Muhammad that is since the seventh
century it has evolved over time and
historically it would have been
patronized by rulers and the wealthy it
would have been in the center of a city
but in the 20th century the building of
large monumental mosques has been
co-opted by the state and that's
something that I'm really interested in
in and my book focuses on these state
mosques in particular in the
contemporary Middle East I focus on four
countries in particular that is the
Turkish Republic the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia the Islamic Republic of Iran
and the United Arab Emirates and I look
at the way in which these four countries
have sponsored monumental state mosques
within their own borders but also
outside of their country themselves so
is it only the state states that are
building mosques there are there any
private mosques being built there are
private mosques I mean you know building
a mosque is a benevolent act so if you
have the means you might want to
consider building a mosque or
patronising one but what I'm really
interested is in the way in which these
four states because what I argue in the
book is that these four states represent
what might be the vision for the Muslim
world today so Iran Turkey Saudi Arabia
and the United Arab Emirates have a
vision for what they think of the Muslim
community now today and they're using
these state-sponsored mosques as a way
of propagating their ideology
disseminating their thoughts for what
this Muslim community might be and so
that's my focus primarily I'm not really
looking at every type of I was but this
very particular typology and what led
you to this project I was actually
nominated for a Carnegie Award a few
years ago by a colleague at UCLA Lynn
hunt and the mandate of that cycle of
award was to understand the Muslim world
today or the modern Muslim world as you
mentioned my work has also been and
primarily has been on the early modern
period and so what I wanted to think of
was what is the role of history in
modern Islam so that was my starting
point and I wanted to look at this form
of architecture which again as I
mentioned is ubiquitous but since at
least 30 years
modern mosques in the Middle East or in
fact you could say all over the Islamic
world are very historical that they make
these very powerful historical
references for example mosques built by
the Turkish Republic our Ottoman inform
right so they are going back to the
classical 16th century
to define a particular type of
architecture and I was very curious to
understand why why is it that they are
going so far deep into the past and what
does history mean in this context
so what is at stake and now this idea of
going back historically is not unique to
the Islamic world and certainly in the
past 30 years we've seen the rise of
religion and the rise of a historical
consciousness in many religious
communities whether it's fundamentalism
seen in Christian communities or Hindu
communities so it's a very particular
aspects of of this moment in time and
that's what I really was curious to find
out more about and through the mosque is
very visible symbol of that and how did
you do the research for the project well
I I'm an architectural historian as you
mentioned so fieldwork is really
important and so I was traveling to
these four countries themselves but also
to countries where I argue they sponsor
or gift their ambassadorial types of
state mosques so I was also traveling to
Syria to Pakistan to Europe Germany and
other parts in the Middle East which I
think are sort of connected through
through these four primarily sites I was
doing photo documentation architectural
documentation trying to understand who
was using the mosques so there's some
sort of anthropological aspect to it I
was able in many cases to interview the
builders the architects and some cases
the patrons so there's many many levels
with which I was trying to understand
the institution from very different
angles does it vary from country to
country mm-hmm very much so in terms of
the architectural patronage and what it
means you know so for example as I
mentioned the Turkish Republic is
building these of what would be known as
neo art amendments but they're building
them in very different parts of the
world
from Tokyo to Turkmenistan to Germany
and more closed by as well so so the way
in which the Turkish Republic is
defining its spheres of influence if you
will is very different from say Iran
right that is using Shiism for example
as it's linked and what's binding it so
the Iranian government has sponsored a
great deal of mosque building and shrine
reconstructions in Syria in Iraq in
Lebanon so each of these countries has a
very different way of going about this
sponsorship and that's what I was really
curious to find out more okay and let's
define the term transnational versus a
traditional mosque you mentioned them
building mosques and other countries is
that smart a transnational term exactly
exactly and and and I think what I
wanted to do was to try and find a way
of distinguishing this idea of say the
global right because that's a term that
has also been used when we're talking
about the contemporary period there are
other ways of thinking about same
abilities is another way in which people
have talked about community is going
beyond national borders and certainly
media and so on allow us to do that but
what I argue in the book and why I
really am committed to the term
transnational is that I think the nation
is still at the center of political
discourse particularly in the
contemporary Middle East that is to say
that the types of decision making public
policy the way in which public's are
created themselves are really from the
point of view of the state and the
nation and so whether the buildings are
within the sovereign boundaries of a
country such as Iran or Turkey or the
United Arab Emirates or outside I argue
that it's still the national that is
playing into these decisions making and
how is that decision-making reflected in
the actual building of the mosque I mean
I speak to specific countries yeah yeah
yeah no certainly so the choices
for example where these mosques will be
barracks right so for example the Saudi
government in the 1980s sponsored of
what is now understood to be the
national mosque in Pakistan in Islamabad
which is known as the King Faisal mosque
it was completed in 1986 and it's named
after King Faisal who is the ruler of
Saudi Arabia before his death and this
mosque is given as a gift in a sense to
the people of Pakistan now as you know
Saudi Arabia and Pakistan have very long
traditional ties political ties
ideological ties and that link is
reinforced through this monumental
mosque the fact that is named after King
vessel even though it's built in
Pakistan continues that link
similarly the the government of Abu
Dhabi has built what is now understood
to be the second largest mosque in and
around Jerusalem after the al-aqsa
mosque which was built in the end of the
seventh century which is named after
Sheikh Zayed there's a founder and the
ideologue of the United Arab Emirates
and so what they're doing is really
creating as I mentioned alliances now in
some cases as I mentioned religion might
be what defines that connection so for
Saudi Arabia and Pakistan or for Iran
and Syria in other cases that might be
some linguistic or ethnic identity for
example Turkey when they are building
for the diasporas or for what they see
as the political links to the
post-soviet republics right which are
Turkic and they'll have a linguistic and
ethnic connection to Turkey although
there are thousands of miles away so
they're making a different kind of a
connection and resurrecting the Ottoman
Empire in a way to make that link
how many mosques are being built around
the country I mean are many
there's you know one or two here that's
a wonderful question and again it varies
so primarily one would argue that when
the states are building their national
mosque it is often won in their capital
so that would be the primary mosque but
interestingly what they build outside of
their own borders are not limited they
are strategically placed within other
capital cities or or in other areas
where there might be some reason to be
for example again the United Arab
Emirates is building a very monumental
mosque in shim Kent and one of the
reasons is because they both
oil-producing nations that's not a very
big capital and one hardly knows very
much about it but once you dig a little
bit deeper you realize that there's a
lot of oil that is being surveyed and
brought out in that region and so
there's a commercial venture there's a
commercial connection that is being
brought up between these two
oil-producing nations and it must help
to strengthen the ties between the two
it's kind of a key diplomatic gift all
Massoud yeah exactly and that's what I
do call them a diplomatic or
ambassadorial mosques because they
precisely perform that function so
looking at the the history of the mosque
over time has the political significance
of the mosque changed
I think the mosque has always been a
space of political action historically
it was believed that the first mosque
was the Prophet Muhammad's house where
he met with his community and they
discussed ideas about where that
community was going what was next and so
on so the mosque is traditionally and
continues to be a place where the
community gathers and discusses it's
sort of agenda its vision and it would
have traditionally been the purview of
the ruler for example to decide what was
being discussed in the sermon for
example the friday mosque
or the communication and mask which is
what these large state-sponsored
national mosques are our places where
the Muslim community meets on Friday
afternoons that sort of is the major day
that one sort of congregates and at that
time there will be a sermon and goodbye
as it's known in which the most
important issues of the day are going to
be discussed right so that was politics
most often the not in fact the Iranian
government for example today
that's the sermons that are going to be
presented at these friday mosques and
then they are disseminated throughout
the country so it remains and continues
to be a very political space and and
even as it impacts the sort of super
structure of of people's lives it's also
the mosque is also part of the everyday
life of people right so it's a community
space and I think that intersection is
what makes it such a powerful symbol for
the contemporary world even now yeah
okay I'm I'm wondering when a country
wants to build a mosque outside of its
own country yeah I would imagine that
that country needs to have a buy-in and
have you when talking with the ark the
architects what does that process like
did you discuss that at all right well
let's think of the example of what is
known as the Amin Mosque in Beirut and I
had the opportunity to meet with the
architect Asma [ __ ] who's was very
forthcoming very interesting he's a
local Beirut the architect the Amin
Mosque is huge it's right in the center
next to martyr square it's one of the
most monumental buildings in Beirut it
was funded by the Saudi government and
it's something that was negotiated
between at that time Rafiq Hariri who
was the president and the Saudi
government with which he had very strong
historical ties because he had lived
there and his company
was there as well so it was negotiated
and that's what is interesting about
this the types of negotiations that take
place between countries right like what
for instance well you know for example
that this is a gift that has been given
the the Lebanese government at the time
recognized that they needed a symbol of
their authority and their strongest
supporters were the Saudis and so they
went to them and said you know we need
to build this mosque it has to be
martyrs square that whole area had been
devastated and they needed to build
something as you know of course Beirut
is divided by religious factionalism
sectarianism and so to build this huge
mosque which interestingly enough looks
also Ottoman it's supposed to be
inspired according to the architect by
the Blue Mosque in Istanbul okay a lot
of these Moscow inspired by the Blue
Mosque upon in Istanbul very interesting
reasons and why I asked well you know
it's it's interesting because that was
or it's understood today to be the
symbol of the Ottoman Empire which of
course you know was the longest rail run
aim it was you know in existence for
almost six hundred years this was the
caliphate this was the most powerful
Muslim empire historically in up you
know from 1200 and something until 1918
so you know almost 600 years the
Ottomans ruled over a very broad swath
of land from you know the reaches of
Europe to North Africa to Asia so so the
Ottomans are held in high regard by
everyone almost people at least and so
it was interesting to see that even for
the Saudi government when they're
sponsoring a mosque in Beirut they are
using that symbol but in a very
different and distinct way than the
Turkish government itself okay so so
there's these negotiations being taken
that are taking place between the
governments between local actors when
the amin mosque was opened for example
the mufti of there
was brought in to pray there and to help
inaugurate it so many different members
of the community and of the city were
mobilized in order to inaugurate this
building okay and what about the mosque
moving forward what do you think the
future holds well you know what has been
really interesting to me has been to
realize that in each of these countries
the idea of the mosque is quite distinct
that has evolved in in the past 30 years
as a very distinct entity so for example
in Ankara the the large what would be
considered state mosque is the coach
attempt a mosque it was built through
the support of the Republic had been the
refa party the welfare party at the time
it projects this incredible populism the
whole ground floor of it is a
supermarket and the parking lots Wow and
so people come they park their cars this
was shopping then that's very unusual is
it well actually it's not that's what's
so interesting that I've never heard of
that yes well you know mosques often had
a foundation that was attached to them
they were close to a bazaar
or they were close to some other kind of
commercial venture that helped
supplement its own income and that would
have been an endowment that was part of
the mosque well what the coach at EBI
has done is taken this modern form right
so of the supermarket of the parking
garage but indeed typologically it's not
that distinct but what it has done is
it's responding to its time right right
so it's got this incredible populism
consumerism to it and so that projects
an idea of what the Turkish government
sees as its pillars of strength now
right yeah and I would imagine really
draws people to the mosque for a variety
of reason from Quran classes for
children for adults learning Arabic a
whole slew of activities take place
there now in contrast and I think this
is also interesting to note is that the
United Arab Emirates for example has its
national mosques for example desired
more
in a booth hobby which is monumental
it's incredibly large and beautiful they
have not chosen one style because the
the idea was that she excited wanted to
build a country in the nation that
brought people from all over the world
and so that mosque makes references to
many different historical periods many
different countries they've brought in
artisans from India from North Africa
the design of the mosaics is by this
British artist so they brought the world
to themselves and that's part of the way
in which the United Arab Emirates wants
to project its vision of Islam second
these mosques the state mosques in the
United Arab Emirates are also community
centers but also cultural centers so
they are open to non-muslims and they
see as part of their mandate to be open
to a very wide community to teach them
about Islam and to project a vision of a
tolerant progressive Islam so that is
very different from what the Turkish
case is but it tells us a lot about how
the United Arab Emirates sees itself
today and moving forward so the mosque
is part of this the idea it's part of
the vision for these countries and how
they want to see themselves both within
their own national sovereignties but
also how they want to project themselves
to the world and that's why it's been
such an exciting project you know to
discover both this internal and external
discourse and when when can we expect
your book to be out next year thank you
so much for being here thank you for
more information about Professor rizvi
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu / Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale